assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends today we're going to do a
little experiment we're going to go to
muslim girls give them my phone with a
little message on it and see what
reaction we're going to get in chava
follow me and let's see what happens
just i just wanted you to read that
[Music]
uh we've got a second
just read that
just to read this
sorry have you got a second
sorry have you guys got a second to just
read this
read it
[Music]
oh thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
god bless you guys and i genuinely mean
this
we're going around to doing a little
experiment yeah
yeah
yeah
thank you
yes
okay guys so we carried out this
experiment some of you guys maybe were
expecting something else but no what we
did was wanted to give them that message
from the heart genuinely believing every
single word that i say and meaning it
for those sisters inshallah
now why did i do this video why did i
find the need to do it the reason why i
found the need to do is because i'm
being honest with you yes i do give
reminders to sisters yes i do give
reminders to sisters in youtube you know
who misrepresent their hijab
but
that does not mean that we have this
hatred towards them of course we don't
we do it because we care about our
sisters but a lot of the time a lot of
youtubers all they do is attack sisters
and all they do is talk about the things
that they don't do but why don't we ever
talk about the things that they do and
the struggles that they're going through
in the west and they're living in the
west with all these hardships and
instead of helping them and elevating
them and praising them we push them
further down i want to stop this trend
that's the reason why i did this video
and i had nothing to lose giving that
little message giving my phone to them
and then reading that that seeing them
getting happy over that statement showed
me how much that they are actually dying
for this you know and we don't lose
anything and i'm not asking anybody any
brothers to just randomly go and date
this to sisters is just to put a point
across that we should better ourselves
the reason why i wanted to do this is
because allah says in the uh surah
30
that
those who believed and did righteous
deeds indeed never think that your deeds
are going to go to waste that allah is
going to reward you
and this is what is this is one of the
reasons why i wanted to come out and
tell my dear sisters because a lot of
the time you're getting all these things
from all kinds of places and on top of
that people are encouraging you to take
your hijab off and you've got people who
for other reasons they're taking hijabs
off people of influence and this may
have affected you that's the reason why
i wanted to come to you guys
specifically today and give this message
and say may allah grant every single one
of you guys jannah in this hot weather
wearing that hijab against all odds so
that was my message brothers and sisters
may allah bless you guys and never ever
forget
every action you're doing don't ever
think that it's going to be unanswered
allah is going to reward every single
time
you that sweat every single drop of
sweat that's dripping from you well
you're going to reward this all my
sisters keep strong we'll lie as your
brothers we are proud of you may allah
bless you guys share this video with
your friends and family until next time
goodbye